well for more than a month now
New York has forced quote non-essential
businesses to close what are
non-essential well we'll say what is
essential liquor stores are very much
essential according to New York
everything else pretty much is
non-essential but now some of those
non-essential people have decided to
defy the city ban le Rabine owns the
Peter Elliot blue men's fashion boutique
in New York Rabine says that his store
is open for business and there's no
reason it shouldn't be le noir bean
joins us tonight a very brave man mr.
bean thanks so much for coming on I'm
amazed that you're bold enough to come
on and we're grateful for it why are you
doing this well first of all I just
pleasure to be here pleasure to chat
with you sir I'm kidding
I decided that I did not want anyone to
dictate to me and destroy the soul of my
business which is 43 years old and the
soul of my business is my employees and
when I see that liquor stores and our
essential business well I find that
ludicrous I find that liquor stores can
be frankly existentially dangerous so I
opened it's true with the idea where I
opened with the idea that I want to
protect my people protect my country and
I'm not I'm not going to allow someone
to dictate to me with something they'd
have no idea so this morning or this
afternoon actually the police came they
came in they said are you open I said my
door is open I haven't been in my shop
for three weeks we've been closed we owe
a lot of money to a lot of people we've
applied to every government agency that
you could possibly think of we've got
registration numbers and we've heard
nothing back but we did hear that the
Shake Shack and Ruth Chris etc etc and
and the cruise ships are getting my
taxes that's ludicrous
this country's backbone of businesses
like mine all over our country I don't
find myself being brave I find myself
being reasonable I find myself having
common sense so
doors open the rules are posted on the
door we're observing every single rule
and regulation that's come down and they
come go ahead sir well I'm just
wondering what happened when the police
came so the the police asked you are you
open you said indeed I am and then what
did they say did they give you a ticket
no sir they did not
in fact they looked at me they said
you're a veteran I said yes I am thank
you for your service I thank you for
your service I am open to clean my store
clean my inventory and if people want to
walk in they're allowed to walk in I am
NOT forcing them in I am NOT a
hairdresser
where I'm close I'm not a manicurist I'm
not a barber I'm a retail store and I'm
open to the public and if they want to
walk in I'm not going to stop them from
walking in if they want to buy I'm not
going to stop them we've maintained our
distance and we avoid we've obeyed every
single rule but I feel that this country
is being dictated to unnecessarily I
think that personally I'm putting no one
in danger look I've had seven angyeo I
just heard you a little while ago I have
said seven angioplasties for students
high blood pressure and peripheral
artery disease and I'm vertical after
this conversation I wish we'd open the
show with you tonight and gone for 20
minutes because you are you're my kind
of American and I hope that you're
rewarded for this and I hope that if you
have any problems you will come back on
this show and in the meantime I hope New
Yorkers will support you in what you're
doing
god bless you good luck and I hope
you'll tell us what happens good I will
do across the country thank you sir
amen thank you I hope we see you again